Вже пішло вправдання що Зеленського
вважають відповідальним це не означає що
він винен Я перепрошую у нас з останніх
4 роки моно моно влада в україні і
привів цю моно владу за собою Зеленський
своїм іменем тому що більшість людей які
йшли за ним вони не мали ні статусу Ні
імені ні якоїсь історії за собою і так
він за це відповідальний і так як лідер
держави яким він себе хоче вважати яким
він час від часу є не зокрема на
міжнародних форумах він себе добре
де-не-де позиціонує він має ці питання
вирішувати а не нарікати там не через
своїх підгавкувачів на опозицію на
соціологи чи ще щось на кого він казав
що треба садити найближчим друзів Ну то
давай почну з цього